antenne de 20 heures le journal de la
rédaction Henri Sannier bonsoir émotion
à Mathausen en Autriche témoignage
devant une prison dans la région
parisienne interview exclusive sur fond
de scandale à la Bourse de Paris ce sont
les temps forts du journal en voici tout
de suite le sommaire
le trou de plus de 500 millions de
francs dans les contes de la société
française de bourse un gestionnaire
désigné comme coupable s'explique sur
Antenne 2
Jean-Paul II camp de concentration de
matausanne en Autriche hommage aux
victimes du nazisme en l'absence du
président valdagne et appelle la ne pas
oublier trop vite l'enfer
sécheresse record aux États-Unis
agriculture sinistrée dans au moins 30
états des céréaliers sur tous les
éleveurs durement frappés
dialogue et témoignage au petit matin
devant la prison de Fresnes dans la
région parisienne c'est l'image que nous
avons choisi de vous présenter en
ouverture du journal au lendemain de la
grâce présidentielle et après le vote du
projet d'amnistie 4500 détenus vous le
savez vont sortir progressivement de
prison il n'y aura pas de sortie massif
car les autorités veillent à l'accueil
et surtout à la réinsertion des détenus
pour certains c'était aujourd'hui déjà
le jour J l'image que vous allez voir
est synonyme de liberté mais aussi
d'interrogations reportages Hervé
bruszini berniemerio pour les images
l'air libre depuis hier il ne pense qu'à
ça tout ce condamnés à de courtes peines
les voilà touchées par la grâce
présidentielle soit 15 à 20 jours de
moins derrière les barons une question
pourtant trotte dans la tête de Béchir
Louis et Jacques et maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'on fait
on a la rue on va dehors on respire
dehors maintenant on s'en va voilà je me
trouve dans la rue comme ça sans argent
est-ce que vous savez s'il y a des lieux
est-ce qu'on vous est tenu informé pour
vous dire vous pouvez aller là où là on
m'a donné un papier ce matin mais
j'ai pas encore allé vous a donné un
papier vous pouvez nous montrer là
vous êtes libéré de prison vous n'avez
pas de domicile vous n'avez pas d'emploi
ah bah voilà donc c'est là qu'on vous
dit quand même où il faut aller ça on
m'a pas dit
ce que c'était que ce paquet
d'accord en plus j'ai pas de lunettes
pour pour mieux lire
voilà faut que tu peux aller là et tout
parce que
de toute façon c'est c'est les trucs que
bon on va se retrouver déjà devant des
juges devant des procureurs des trucs
comme ça déjà moi ça m'est arrivé il m'a
regardé comme ça il m'a dit mais il va
retourner en prison celui-là de toute
façon c'est des trucs comme ça alors
c'est pour se sentir mal c'est pas la
peine
tout au fond les procureurs les juges à
quoi bon quand on est un ancien
prisonnier seul dans une ville inconnue
avec 100 francs en poche on y va au
service d'accueil ou plutôt auraios
derrière ce nom barbare une initiative
sans précédent ici l'ex détenu est prise
en charge par tous les services
concernés réunis en un lieu unique
c'est la mise en commun des énergies des
réflexions
pour pendant cette période spécifique
d'éviter à tout prix si l'on peut dire
la récidive mobilisation générale donc
pour que les ex prisonniers bénéficient
de leurs droits sociaux et de quoi se
loger aucune somme en espèces n'est
remis seulement des tickets restaurants
ou un billet de métro une difficulté
majeure leur trouver un emploi les
patrons tous les industriels qui
pourraient avoir ne serait-ce que des
idées sur la question je veux dire ou
des renseignements leur lançant un appel
pour qu'il puisse nous joindre et nous
proposer des solutions
venir en débattre avec nous s'il le
souhaite pour Béchir l'affaire semble
régler à présent il déguste ce qu'il
appelle le sandwich de la liberté
Jacques lui a préféré retrouver son ami
la semaine prochaine c'est juré il ira
voir son éducatrice
la première des choses actuellement
j'ai besoin d'oxygène j'ai besoin de me
remettre un peu mise en place et surtout
besoin qu'on m'aide
voilà sachez encore que les anciens
détenus ne touchent aucune somme
d'argent à la sortie de prison la vue
aujourd'hui l'aide leur est fourni
simplement par le centre d'accueil dont
je vous rappelle d'ailleurs les
coordonnées les voici quatre 14 rue
Ferrus Paris 14e le numéro de téléphone
c'est le 45 88 93 93
Jean-Paul II en Autriche au-delà des
controverses c'est l'image de l'émotion
qui s'impose ce soir après avoir évoqué
la grande épreuve et la tyrannie subie
par l'Autriche sous le nazisme il y a
quelques années le Souverain Pontife
s'est rendu tout à l'heure au camp de
Mathausen Jean-Paul II était seul sans
cour de valdime Jean-Marc Hillhouse
seul pour aller se recueillir aux camps
de concentration l'asile malthausen le
Vatican avait fait savoir que le pape
serait seul en clair mais sans le dire
explicitement comme l'aurait souhaité la
communauté juive autrichienne le pape
n'était pas comme hier ici accompagné du
président autrichien courbes côte
val-dime interdit de séjour aux
États-Unis en raison de l'ambiguïté de
son rôle d'anciennes officier de
renseignement dans une unité allemande
coupable d'être aussi
avant cet hommage au Sandy mille
victimes juives tzigane et polonaise du
nazisme le pape avait rencontré la
communauté juive de Vienne et prêché
pour une dignité égale pour les peuples
juifs et palestiniens ce matin lors
d'une masse en plein air c'est au monde
communiste tout proche que c'était
adressé Jean-Paul II une mise en garde
je cite aux hommes qui croient pouvoir
se passer de Dieu près de 100 000
pèlerins avaient franchi les frontières
de Tchécoslovaquie ou de Hongrie pour
approcher le Souverain Pontife un homme
qu'il ne voit pas chez eux à la
télévision
au-delà d'un grand moment d'émotion
arrêtons-nous quelques instants à
Mathausen un camp qui est situé sur le
Danube au nord-est de l'Autriche
matthausen c'était l'image de l'horreur
au quotidien tour à tour camp de travail
et camps d'extermination reportage de
Philippe Rochot
un homme en franchi
les ponts de markhausen depuis la fin de
la guerre mais si Jean-Paul II a
voulu baraquement ou 200000 hommes
attendaient chaque jour le rendez-vous
de la mort c'est pour rendre hommage à
Marcel Callo missionnaire français né à
Rennes qui a vécu là le martyre des
déportés pendant deux ans et qui vient
d'être béatifié
sa foi de jeunes militants des jeunesse
ouvrières chrétiennes lui a permis de
survivre dans les conditions de travail
les plus dures dans les usines
d'armement de Gusen à côté du camp de
maouthausen
dans le camp des courses c'était la rue
très dur dans le camp de gussein de la
vie était plus dure qu'ici à Mao talusen
nous dit Garcia manuel qui a passé
quatre ans ici pourtant Marcel calot
priait et organisait des messes
clandestines à gussein on mourait plus
que dans le camp de maouthausen et 60%
des morts venaient de ce camp de travail
Marcel Callo est donc mort ici aux côtés
des 110 000 victimes du travail forcé
qui ont péri dans la carrière de
maothausen écrasé sous les blocs qu'ils
n'ont pas pu remonter battu à mort par
les gardiens ou précipités du haut de la
falaise 30 000 polonais ont également
trouvé la mort à maothausen c'était
aussi pour leur rendre hommage que
Jean-Paul II a voulu venir ici par
simple respect pour ceux qui sont tombés
le pape aura donc franchi sans le
président autrichien cour de valdime les
portes de Mao thausen
au palais Bourbons après l'élection sans
grande surprise de Laurent Fabius hier à
la Présidence de l'Assemblée nationale
c'était aujourd'hui l'élection du bureau
un Bureau qui est composé de 6
vice-présidents trois testeurs et 12
secrétaires là encore pas de grosses
surprises il faut dire que des ce matin
les présidents des 4 groupes politiques
étaient parvenus à un accord la
prochaine étape plus difficile sans
doute sera l'élection des présidents de
commission Pascal Guimier la façade
qu'on sensuelle est bouchée hier aura
tenu 5 minutes 5 minutes de séance
publique le temps d'annoncer que le
bureau de l'assemblée était constitué
avec l'assentiment de tous les groupes
c'est ensuite aurémy cycle que tous est
rapidement gâté les socialistes avaient
décidé de laisser deux présidences de
commission l'opposition une pour l'UDF
l'autre pour les centristes tout ce
serait donc passé dans le meilleur des
mondes politiques possible si et bien si
aujourd'hui le RPR n'avait rué dans les
brancards résolu à jouer les opposants
durs et purs les gaulliste refuse tous
ceux qui pourraient ressembler de près
ou de loin à une entente de la gauche et
le centre une grosse pierre dans le
jardin UDF résidence de commission qui
sont octroyées aujourd'hui sous forme de
bol par le Parti socialiste risque
d'entrer peu de temps de se retourner
contre ceux qui les auraient acceptés
imaginez la position d'un président de
commission qui aurait été élu dans ces
conditions aujourd'hui et qui demain se
trouverait en minorité au sein de sa
commission le RPR demande donc à ses
alliés de présenter des candidats
communs pour toutes les présidents de
commissions les socialistes eux sans
lavent les mains que la droite règle
c'est différent en famille l'offre
centriste elle tient toujours
nous laissons le bout-père mettre de son
analyse nous maintenons nos positions
elles ont été acceptées nous les
mettrons en oeuvre c'est pour nous un
contrat de bons comportement que nous
avons engagé ce soir la balle est donc
dans le camp de l'UDF l'élection des
présidents de commissions aura lieu
mardi prochain la journée s'annonce
mouvementée oui de source autorisées
j'ajoute que l'on apprend ce soir que le
deuxième gouvernement de Michel roc
devrait être formé mardi soir et se
réunir mercredi matin à 10h au Palais de
l'Elysée autour du chef de l'État
François Mitterrand on indique cependant
la précision est importante que la
formation du nouveau gouvernement
pourrait être retardée si le Conseil
européen danove en RFA auquel
participent le chef de l'État se
prolongeait mardi soir un peu plus tard
que prévu la politique en bref 15 jours
après les élections législatives le
Journal officiel publie aujourd'hui la
liste des recours auprès du Conseil
constitutionnel 20 recours
officiellement certains départements
sont particulièrement concernés on a
trois recours dans les Hauts-de-Seine de
recours dans le Nord idem pour Paris et
la Seine-Maritime à Marseille où l'on
pense déjà semble-t-il beaucoup aux
élections municipales on ne sait
toujours pas qui de Michel peset ou de
Robert Vigouroux le maire actuel
défendra l'an prochain les couleurs
socialistes la mission de conciliation
tentait ce matin par Louis Mermaz et
Pierre Mauroy ces soldé par un échec a
priori ce sont les militants qui
trancheront sur le terrain cette fois
des précisions sur l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie partisan et
adversaire de l'indépendance ont
participé hier à une première réunion de
travail à l'Hôtel Matignon les deux
délégations se retrouveront mardi
prochain pour l'instant on a tout juste
dépassé les échanges de politesse c'est
le cas de le dire dès la semaine
prochaine le gouvernement devrait
soumettre à ses interlocuteurs un schéma
de proposition dont voici les grandes
lignes Dominique tiers
en lui-même l'intitulé de ce texte
illustre la méthode Rocard 9 points qui
ouvrent la discussion sans pour autant
définir trop précisément les contours le
gouvernement propose aux deux
délégations un calendrier sur 10 ans
pour les prochains 12 mois le territoire
serait géré directement par Paris
parallèlement un statut transitoire
serait en vigueur jusqu'en 1998 un
scrutin d'autodétermination fixerait à
l'issue de ses 10 ans l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et tous les Français
seraient appelés à se prononcer sur ce
schéma par référendum d'une certaine
manière ce texte a plongé l'ensemble des
délégations dans la perplexité pour
Jean-Marie jibaou l'acceptation d'un tel
calendrier semble difficile les
indépendantistes souhaitent que la
France s'engage clairement sur le droit
du peuple kanak a revendiqué
l'indépendance sur les conditions pour y
parvenir d'ici 5 ans deux points
essentiels soigneusement évitées par le
texte des propositions
aucun commentaire de Jacques Lafleur
mais tout laisse croire qu'il
accueillerait avec satisfaction le délai
de 10 ans pour le scrutin
d'autodétermination en revanche il
pourrait s'interroger sur le silence
entourant la composition du corps
électoral la question clé du dossier
calédonien qui pourra participer à la
consultation il y a quelques semaines
souvenez-vous nous en parlions dans ce
journal de 20h la bourse était secouée
par un scandale on apprenait
officiellement que la chambre syndicale
des agents de change ou l'ex chambre des
agents de change avait perdu 500
millions de francs sur le MATIF qui est
le marché à terme des instruments
financiers très vite les soupçons se
portaient sur un gestionnaire de la
Chambre Syndicale l'homme qui pour
l'instant avait fait preuve d'une très
grande discrétion a finalement accepté
de parler sur Antenne 2 reportage
Jean-Pierre Métivet
c'est le plus gros scandale boursier ce
jour-là Xavier Dupont le président de la
Société des bourses françaises
l'ancienne compagnie des agents de
change va démissionner il vient de
reconnaître une perte de 500 millions de
francs sur le natif l'un des marchés les
plus spéculatifs
le fond de garantie de la profession une
sorte d'assurance
d'épargnants en cas de faillite d'un
professionnel très officiel c'est 500
millions de francs ont été perdus en
plein krach boursiers fin 1987 le
responsable serait un ancien
collaborateur licencié début 88 l'homme
qui porte ainsi le chapeau le voici
c'est lui qui gérait les fonds du
syndicat des agents de change
aujourd'hui il parle mais contredit la
thèse officielle sur le montant et les
conditions de cette perte
quel était le montant des fonds que vous
aviez à gérer deux milliards de francs
et est-ce qu'on vous a dit qu'il
s'agissait du fond de garantie à aucun
moment cette précision m'a été apportée
qu'il s'agissait du fond de garantie
vous l'auriez gérer d'une autre façon il
est évitable que le sachant un surcroît
de prudence aurait été mise lorsque vous
êtes parti
le montant des pertes s'est levées à
combien
170 millions de francs alors les 330
millions
qui manquent pour aboutir à la perte
totale de 500 millions de francs d'où
viennent-ils
malheureusement aucune
raison de savoir ce que ça représente
puisque je n'étais pas
je n'ai plus été responsable de la de la
gestion
qui a été faite après mon départ et donc
je ne peux pas savoir ce qui a été fait
par quelle charge passait l'essentiel
des ordres
les ordres passaient principalement par
deux charges dont
comme il semblait être d'usage par la
charge de du syndic de l'axe syndic
c'est à dire par la charge de Monsieur
Dupont tout à fait
aujourd'hui on apprend que la somme
perdue par la Société des bourses
françaises approcherait plutôt les 650
millions de francs du coup qui les a
perdus à quel moment et pourquoi avoir
gardé le silence aussi longtemps la Cobe
le gendarme de la Bourse décortique
actuellement les contes et pourra
peut-être éclaircir tous ces points
plus 0,8% de chômeurs le mois dernier en
mai 88 soit 2 millions
558 800 chômeurs un mauvais chiffre qui
dépasse vous l'avez compris des
prévisions les plus pessimistes peut-on
avancer quelques explications genre
Leclerc d'écouter 20 000 demandeurs de
plus en un mois c'est la plus forte
hausse depuis mars 87 Michel Rocard
avait annoncé dans ses premières
déclarations cette brutale détérioration
qui rappelle celle de 1983 et de 1986 ce
n'est donc pas une surprise mais ce
n'est pas non plus une consolation
l'explication c'est pour l'essentiel un
tarissement des stages organisés par le
précédent gouvernement pour les jeunes
de 16 à 25 ans et les chômeurs de longue
durée il y a eu le mois dernier 20 000
sorties de stage de plus qu'il n'y a eu
d'entrée et la tendance va se poursuivre
du fait des vacances notamment jusqu'en
août où les statistiques de l'emploi
auront enregistré quasi mécaniquement
150 000 demandeurs d'emploi
supplémentaires ce n'est qu'à partir de
septembre que le gouvernement espère en
rayer ce flux montant avec l'ouverture
de 25 place dans les centres de
formation voilà en tout cas une nouvelle
démonstration que sans la béquille du
traitement social l'économie française
ne crée pas suffisamment d'emplois une
situation d'autant plus préoccupante
qu'en Grande-Bretagne le chômage baisse
de façon continue depuis 2 ans et qu'aux
États-Unis ne touchent plus que 5 % de
la population contre plus de 10% chez
nous merci Gérard les États-Unis
parlons-en les États-Unis victimes de la
sécheresse jour après jour la situation
se dégrade aujourd'hui une trentaine
d'états peut-être 40 serait au bord de
l'asphyxie dans la middle ouest 10% des
récoltes de maïs sont perdus des
troupeaux entiers sont conduits à
l'abattoir à la Bourse des produits
agricoles de Chicago les prix sont en
hausse de près de 20 à 25% bref le
scénario traditionnel est classique des
raisins de la colère refait surface avec
en toile de fond des images de poussière
et une terre synonyme de désolation
enquête de Jacques à Bouchard et Jo
Thomas pour les images les habitants de
Clyde bourgade agricole de le Rayo ce
sont d'abord réfugiés dans la prière
réuni autour de leur prêtres ils ont
imploré le ciel mais n'ont pas été
entendus pas le moindre nuage à
l'horizon après six semaines sans pluie
alors ils ont fait appel au grand
sorcier indien crowdock chien qui aboie
il garantissait le succès de l'opération
moyennant 2000 dollars
et ses assistants ont multiplié les
champs les danses et les incantations
aux divinités
mais le soleil a continué de les narguer
la terre s'est encore un peu plus
craquelée et les maigres blancs de maïs
sont menacés de destruction totale s'il
ne pleut pas d'ici le premier juillet
tous les Midwest constitué des grandes
plainesées et de la ceinture de maïs vit
dans la même peur Bill bischold un
arboriculteur de 48 ans affirme avoir
jamais connu par les situations
l'année passée l'été la tempe du pluie
en hiver pas de neige depuis janvier une
banque plus de 20 cm de pluie
ce boulet maintenant regardez l'arbre
dans le sillage de son tracteur le roi
et burkin soulève un nuage de poussière
rien de plus il possède 300 hectares
dont la moitié planté en soja il a
ensemencé ce champ aux alentours du 15
mai
6 semaines plus tard dit-il les graines
sont dures comme des cailloux il n'y a
pas eu germination
sauvera le tiers de sa récolte
les plantes fourragères destinées à
l'alimentation du bétail sont les plus
touchés par la pénurie d'eau prenons
l'exemple du soja dont voici un champ en
cette période de l'année la terre
devrait disparaître sous un tapis de
verdure on est loin du compte la
situation est à ce point critique que le
ministre de l'Agriculture évoque le
risque d'un désastre national
pour le sorcier indien et son équipe qui
se livre à une séance de purification
rien n'est perdu
recueillement méditation imposition des
mains crowdog et convaincu que ses
efforts ne resteront pas vains
d'ailleurs quelques gouttes d'eau sont
tombées au quatrième jour des prières
salué par ce commentaire désabusé
d'infirmiers il ne reste plus au bon
Dieu que ses yeux pour pleurer les
télégrammes d'actualité avec Isabelle
stess ensuite nous vous expliquerons
comment la police française vient de
démanteler un réseau de voleurs
d'antiquités
distension si Jordanie un colon
israélien était grièvement blessé à coup
de poignard aujourd'hui à Hébron
l'agression a provoqué la colère de la
population autre incident à naplouz un
autre colon israélien attaquer cette
fois-ci à coups de pierre à riposter par
balle si Palestiniens ont été blessés
la grève s'étend Yougoslavie après les
mineurs et les ouvriers du textile les
employés de l'automobile ont cessé le
travail à Maribor pour protester contre
la politique d'austérité du gouvernement
c'est exceptionnel près de 5000
personnes ont manifesté hier dans les
rues
ce petit Raphaël retrouve la vue on l'a
découvert ce matin lors d'un examen
ophtalmologique le garçon né de 3 ans
était devenu aveugle fin avril à la
suite d'une opération du prépuce il
aurait été victime d'un choc
post-opératoire et non pas d'une erreur
médicale
Jean-Paul Kaufman lance un appel en
faveur de la libération des otages du
Silko trois enfants et 6 adultes détenus
depuis plus de 7 mois par le groupe
palestinien bounidal c'est la première
fois que des enfants sont victimes du
terrorisme pourquoi ce silence a déclaré
le journaliste
sans doute l'une des plus belles prises
jamais réalisées en France les policiers
viennent de mettre la main sur un
receleur qui avait entreposé tenez-vous
bien près de 1500 objets d'art et autres
antiquités l'affaire dépasse et de loin
le cadre de la région parisienne
Isabelle Bechler
un ancien brocanteur est sous les
verrous pour Russell pour la bagatelle
de 1500 objets d'art et d'antiquités
retrouvés à Saint-Ouen et dans un dépôt
du département de l'Ain un volume de 140
mètres cubes le produit d'une
cinquantaine de cambriolages Obama des
objets qui peuvent provenir de vol
effectués un peu partout en France et
qui était destiné à l'exportation vers
l'Europe du Nord et vers l'Italie pas de
tableau de maître pas beaucoup de pièces
extrêmement rares mais tout de même de
Bob bronze défaillances de prix et une
commode boule estimée à 400 000 francs
entre autres
c'est un travail classique de police
judiciaire nous sommes partis d'un
certain nombre d'informations que nous
avons recoupé et
à l'issue de plusieurs mois de
surveillance de filature nous avons
réussi à identifier un certain nombre de
lieux où étaient cachés ces objets il y
avait un receleur et plusieurs cavernes
d'Ali Baba
si vous reconnaissez l'un de ces objets
sachez que vous pourrez en consulter les
photographies au siège de l'Office
central de répression du vol d'oeuvre
d'art à Paris le rendez-vous avec votre
pendule adoré passe par le 42 68 03 03
poste
006 voilà j'espère que vous avez bien
noté le numéro ça peut servir une
information qui risque de faire du bruit
dans les heures qui viennent on vient
d'apprendre que plusieurs sociétés
importantes dont Bouygues Flodor et le
GAN serait impliqué il faut parler pour
l'instant au conditionnel dans le trafic
de phos facture qui servait à couvrir
les services d'un réseau de call-girl
c'est tout ce que l'on sait ce soir
peut-être d'autres précisions dans le
dernier journal aux alentours de 22h50
l'un des événements sportifs de l'année
c'est demain après-midi sur Antenne 2 à
partir de 15h30 vous pourrez suivre la
finale de l'Euro foot 88 entre l'URSS et
les Pays-Bas les deux équipes finalistes
ont commencé vous le savez assez
timidement le championnat d'Europe mais
elle termine en bolide qui va gagner
difficile à dire d'un côté il y a le
brio des Hollandais un football
spectacle de l'autre un football
exceptionnel avec des joueurs
d'exception que l'on verra bientôt chez
nous mais oui en France analyse de Jean
mammaire
si l'Europe réussit à dassaief elle
sourit au défenseur soviétique qui dit à
tous ligne il a tapé dans l’œil de
dirigeants français et sera le premier
joueur soviétique en exercice à évolué
dans un championnat hors de son pays
cela ne fait pas sourire l'entraîneur le
banovski qui compte bien sur lui pour la
finale de demain après-midi il est
l'homme de base celui qui tire les coups
francs il est celui qui donne confiance
à ses partenaires l'homme clé de la
défense et de la relance de son équipe
qui dit à Touline c'est peut-être
l'homme de la troisième ouverture
soviétique en Europe lui c'est Erwin
champion d'Europe avec le club de
Malines l'autre c'est ronaldman son
frère champion d'Europe avec le PSV à
Eindhoven
Ervin Koeman c'est l'attaquant de pointe
de l'équipe de Hollande meilleur buteur
et de loin du championnat national
ronaldkman a l'opposé le stoppeur de
l'équipe de Hollande un organisateur qui
ne rechigne pas à tenter de conclure
longtemps fâché l'équipe de Hollande a
rapproché les deux frères un troisième
titre européen celui du championnat
pourrait bien sept fois les réunir
définitivement
le tennis voici en vrac les principaux
résultats de Wimbledon aujourd'hui
qualification pour Stephy graff c'est
pour une surprise d'Anna mendicova et
Pascal paradis chez les hommes victoires
de Boris Baker de pas de cash et d'Henri
Leconte que voici le compte abattu le
Sud-Africain Mohar en 4 recettes vous
l'avez compris Henri Leconte n'a pas
encore trouvé son meilleur rythme
d'autant que le joueur sud-africain
n'est que le 158e joueur mondial
Ray Charles de retour à Paris dans
quelques jours le 30 juin prochain Ray
Charles fera l'ouverture du festival de
Paris au Palais des Sports d'autres
grands noms seront également à l'affiche
comme Miles Davis ou encore airbnc Ray
Charles demeure un véritable mythe pour
les amateurs de jazz témoin sa
prestation hier soir lors d'une soirée
tout à fait privée à laquelle assistée
Yoba Grégoire et Jean-François Kaufman
notre
idole des années 60 toujours top niveau
Ray Charles 63 ans a une sacrée pêche il
swing chantent et décolle toujours
autant tenez découvrez le bas il vaut
bien le haut
pourquoi je reste le numéro 1 depuis si
longtemps c'est parce que je suis
sincère je ne joue pas sur scène quand
je bouge ce n'est pas pour le spectacle
je fais ce que je sens si je bouge c'est
par rapport à la musique
et pour la nostalgie pour le souvenir et
pour nous faire plaisir c'est blouses
sur lesquels beaucoup d'entre nous avons
dansé
voilà dans quelques instants la météo le
bulletin avec José blanc Lapierre vers
22h55 le tout dernier journal présenté
par rubrique samedi 13h20 n'oubliez pas
l'assiette anglaise de Bernard Rapp
pendant le week-end vous retrouverez
Daniel Bilalian et Philippe gasso
bonsoir merci de votre fidélité à partir
de lundi c'est avec l'autre qui vous
tiendra compagnie je vous retrouve pour
ma part début juillet bonsoir excellente
soirée